[Música]
desde que aparecen los primeros rayos de
sol se ven cientos de camellos y con
ellos a cientos de creadores y
comerciantes de todo sudán
el día de mercado es un día muy
importante venimos desde arthur es todo
un viaje casi un mes de viaje con
nuestros camellos para llegar aquí no
hay
el mercado de el molí es uno de los
mayores mercados de camellos de áfrica
aquí no hay vallas ni corrales por lo
que los camellos tienen las patas atadas
para impedir que se alejen
comienza la subasta
un espectáculo increíble los hombres se
susurran los precios al oído un mediador
actúa como enlace entre el comprador y
el vendedor no hay documentos ni
contratos los fajos de billetes pasan de
una mano a otra y el tono a veces sube
rápidamente
para la madre
a estas duras negociaciones forman parte
del juego una especie de póker en el que
hay que saber embaucar
permite es una transacción complicada
ellos vienen de lejos son beduinos y no
dan su confianza fácilmente
aquí en la mayoría de los camellos se
comercializan por su carne que es
especialmente apreciada en el cuerno de
áfrica y en oriente medio un mercado
enorme que exporta 250 mil animales al
año desde sudan
este hombre de negocios es un
comerciante de camellos es su
especialidad sabe cómo elegirlos primero
hay que mirar aquí
hay unos 300 kilogramos de carne tenemos
que revisar cada parte del camello los
museos la joroba su cuello
y estas son las tres partes principales
que hay que mirar y luego hay que mirar
las piernas también si no hay problemas
o lesiones pero no todos los camellos
están destinados al consumo también se
venden para el transporte e incluso para
las carreras en este caso los precios se
disparan
y pueden llegar a superar el millón de
euros por un gran campeón los camellos
de carreras deben ser de la raza abusar
y la mejor y vascas deben ser fuertes
rápidos y tener un temperamento ganador
los camellos siempre han formado parte
de la vida en sudán los nómadas y sus
caravanas han atravesado el país durante
siglos cabe decir que los camellos y los
hombres se conocen desde hace mucho
tiempo según los historiadores sus
caminos se cruzaron desde hace más de
4000 años
[Música]